tragedia aérea en África Oriental un
avión de pasajeros de la aerolínea
precision Air se estrelló en el Lago
Victoria en tanzania cuando se
aproximaba a su destino final las
autoridades informaron que activaron los
protocolos de emergencia de inmediato
nos lamentamos informar que el vuelo
pw494 operado en un avión atr48 viajaba
desde la ciudad de dares a la masia del
aeropuerto de bukova durante su
aproximación la aeronave se accidentó y
cayó sobre el Lago Victoria con 38
adultos un niño y cuatro tripulantes de
cabina el accidente ocurrió en la mañana
del domingo y minutos después la
aerolínea más grande de tanzania informó
que las personas rescatadas fueron
trasladadas para recibir atención médica
a un hospital de caguera Región donde
sucedió el accidente según el canal
Estatal radio televisión nacional de
tanzania el accidente habría sido
causado por las difíciles condiciones
climáticas registrando Fuertes lluvias y
vientos en el momento del accidente
cuando el avión estaba a unos 100 metros
de su destino se encontró con problemas
y mal tiempo estaba lloviendo y la
aeronave se hundió en el agua Todo está
bajo control ya que se han desple de
todos los equipos de rescate y seguridad
para ayudar hemos logrado salvar a un
buen número de personas
un equipo de precision Air y la
autoridad de Aviación civil de tanzania
se desplazaron inmediatamente al lugar
de los hechos para investigar la causa
exacta del accidente